hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered I'm Peter Lavelle
what kind of moment in history are we
living through canvas the status quo be
maintained and will there be a populist
backlash that discuss this and more I'm
joined by my guest
we have onion from our impel she is in
Washington she's the host of red lines
at the gray zone which I strongly
suggest wonderful program particularly
looking after what's his name why doe in
Venezuela I love those episodes in
France we have John Lachlan he's a
political scientist and historian as
well as a lecturer in Europe of European
history at the University Institute of
st. Pius the tenth in Paris and in
Bratislava we crossed the yosef hemmed
in he is a new national relations expert
at Moscow State Institute of
International Relations welcome to
crosstalk all three of you and you're in
my home welcome John I want to give you
two numbers approximate numbers here
that came out last week we have a lot of
turmoil in the financial markets
particularly the stock market which has
basically nothing to do with average
people but we keep hearing about it
anyway they clawed back a lot of the
losses that they've incurred over the
last few weeks but then at the end of
last week over 3 million anything was
3.3 million people million people have
filed for unemployment in the United
States alone so how do you explain those
two numbers at the same time what's that
say about what's going on I think like
everyone else we find it rather
difficult to navigate through these very
stormy waters I've noticed that most
commentators are using the crisis to say
well this all proves that I was right so
for example in the EU pro-eu
commentators say this proves we need
more Europe and anti-eu commentators say
this proves we need less Europe so I
don't see why it should be any different
from everyone else and I'm going to say
that this crisis proves that what I've
been saying all along is true in
response to your particular question I
can only make sense of these paradoxical
figures by saying that the stock
market's
responds to
liquidity in other words free funny
money and all the major producers of
money the eurozone the United States Fed
and the Bank of England have all said in
response to the crisis very early on by
the way long before there was any actual
economic damage they all said we're
going to print gigantic sums of money
even more than we've already been
printing and that's the way we're going
to help people to come out of the crisis
and the stock market typically responds
well to that because it likes the world
of easy credit it likes low interest
rates and so on and it thinks that that
will and also of course it means that
people can borrow money in order to
invest in assets but as you imply in
your question Peter this is coming at a
real economic cost in other words the
stock market index is not reflecting
reality it's perverse obviously for the
index to go up when people get going out
of out of work and like many other
people I'm filled with foreboding and
the effect which this will have
precisely on small people on people who
are self-employed on people who were in
precarious jobs on people who live from
hand to mouth you know the government's
have been very certainly in Europe had
been very grand in promising this and
that president McCoy in France has said
the state will pay well I can assure you
in my own village here in rural France
there are people making goat cheeses who
whose livelihood has been cut off
because they can't because the markets
have been closed markets have been
closed not supermarkets but markets in
other words yes the super companies the
supermarket's the the super corporations
they will be bailed out but as for the
little man I'm not so sure in fact I'm
building reason I want to make this
perma because I think that we're gonna
get a reaction of that yes if let me go
to you in Bratislava it seems when I'm
looking at the coverage here of course
the economy is important for the very
reason that I brought up those
unemployment issues here but at the same
time it seems to me that there's a huge
injection of funny money and John is
absolutely right to preserve the status
quo and not to look about the structural
problems of the neoliberal
project that is is all over the world
okay and in this injection of cash is
just 2008-2009 on steroids all over
again this is an injection of cash that
doesn't really exist to make sure the
system is maintained and maintained for
a very small group of people and we're
going to see over the next few months
irrespective but what happened to this
pandemic we're gonna have a lot of
people unemployed and I think in light
of what happened with the Tea Party and
what the Bernie bros these people are
likely to make it sitting down okay
and I think that the elites have to
worry about a word called pitchfork
because I think that's in the cards go
ahead Joseph yeah here's the US
lawmakers seem to struggle with choosing
between the top court of large
corporations and the protection of
households because when they aim to
tackle the economy crisis they try to
boost economic growth the US economy
model is based on consumption
that's boosting consumption by
stimulation of households why our
welfare state measures are offering
loans to the public might serve as a
buffer at times of crisis alas the US
system like these buffers and recently
approved stimulus illustrates that the
US government has chosen salvation of
large businesses instead of direct
increase of domestic consumption
throughout household supports and
usually at times of economic crisis the
US government lay on these so businesses
boost and and let the labor market to
adapt because it's so inflexible in need
especially in the u.s. such measures
work at times of the calming crisis we
encountered until now however the virus
outbreak is striking on ability of
populations and work well yeah but the
industry is is that you know you with
this with stimulus or bailout or
whatever do you want to call it they
have a lot of flexibility workers don't
like civility at all here you know onion
let me go to you if I can stay with the
American context so do you want to talk
about Europe a little bit later in the
program but you know again looking at
the mainstream coverage
nobody really wants to ask the simple
question I
what would have happened if we had
single-payer health care I wonder what
that is never never ever single time
ever asked and it is the most obvious
question that should come to fore go
ahead I know in fact you have the
opposite you have the corporate media in
the months leading up to this telling us
in the United States why Democratic
voters should not choose the candidate
senator Bernie Sanders from Vermont who
was supportive of syncher single-payer
health care that even though majority of
the population in the United States
supports a program this way this is not
a realistic demand to come from the US
population so not only do you have them
ignoring now the reality faced by many
Americans the fact that we need health
care you actually had them explicitly
tell the working people of this country
that they shouldn't be asking for it and
Peter on your point as to whether it
makes sense that the stock market would
react positively on a week when millions
of working people filed for unemployment
even though this is crosstalk I I
unfortunately have to agree with the two
previous guess if that's not surprising
this is due to the decision by the US
government to pump unlimited amounts of
money into the market not for people
like me not for people in in more or
even less fortunate positions than me
people who aren't working right now
we're getting a measly $1,200 check from
the US government I don't even know when
or how mine is going to arrive let alone
my neighbors or people who might not
even be aware that this money is coming
for them and and I just want to point
out also that today Amazon workers in
the United States are going on a massive
strike so our workers for instacart
which is one of these grocery delivery
services so we're workers at Whole Foods
Whole Foods of course
owned by Amazon owned by Jeff Bezos it's
been partnering with Amazon to deliver
groceries to people throughout the
crisis but workers in these facilities
are saying they don't have simple
protective gear that they need in order
to curb the spread of coronavirus in
their own businesses in fact I saw
people delivering packages to my own
name
who I expected to be covered with at
least a mask or gloves and they weren't
wearing anything like that when they're
handling food so I think this is exactly
the start of what you are talking about
Peter pitchforks actual actual picture
as much as a president thing he's gonna
open the economy by Easter it's gonna be
up to workers to say we're not putting
our body on the line you know but you're
describing feudalism serfdom I think
right now okay and I'm really happy that
you know and John knows me well that I'm
a person from the right but but I do
believe very strongly they populist and
and some members of the left we have so
much in common because my whole stress
is on families and workers and I know we
can find a way together here John you're
nodding your hand here this is what I
think this paradigm shift that I've been
talking about with you for years right
now is that the entire political
calculus is changing here because once
went because this neoliberal project is
amorphous it's a mythology and it
basically is to feel good for elites and
the status quo and and this crisis has
made us at least look at reality the
stark reality of it and I brought up the
word pitchfork it's been already
mentioned again and I'll mention the
third time people are not going to take
this and I look what's going on in the
United States and what's going on in
Europe is that this is an ideology that
is in service of itself and it is not in
service of people go ahead John yeah I
totally agree with with you about that I
think that what the crisis has shown
certainly in Europe is you can almost
plot a graph correlating the level of
health care in individual countries with
the number of deaths and infections from
coronavirus and an inverse graph with
the brutality of the state reaction what
I mean by that is that the states with
the lowest level of healthcare are the
ones with the highest casualties and the
highest fatalities and they are also the
ones that have had to resort to these
terrible methods of confinement these
very brutal almost totalitarian methods
to compensate for the fact
they know that their healthcare systems
are not up to it and when I say
healthcare systems we're talking about
very very basic stuff I'm not even
talking about the fact that there isn't
any testing or that there isn't a cure
even though some doctors say there is a
cure I'm not talking only about the
level of intensive care beds which is
very high in Germany where they have
very few casualties and very low in
Italy in Spain and France where they
have a much higher level I'm talking
about much more basic stuff which the
state has been unable to provide an EUR
mentioned masks just now in France there
are no masks the state had stocks of
masks several years ago they were thrown
away and then what was left was stolen
and when President McCune went on to
television to announce the confinement
he said that masks would be delivered
the day after the day after next
they were never delivered there are no
masks there is no hydro alcoholic hand
wash solution the most basic elements of
simply know these masks cost 30 cents of
simple hygiene are not available because
states have built down over years and as
a result as you say of their neoliberal
program the most basic elements of
health care and they have been caught
with their trousers down it will and
will they be held accountable
accountable for it and that's what I'm
thinking out here yosef let me go back
to you in Bratislava I mean one of the
things that has been highlighted a lot
is its supply chains of this of these
basic very basic medical needs of their
countries have and it's all been
outsourced here and I I'm not in any
mood to start demonizing any particular
country right at this point because I
don't think it helps the conversation
but I think it would be helpful to a
conversation to talk about why and and
the justification for it it has always
been profit when you look at when you
have a medical system that is just
bare-bones this to function and in
particularly in the United States where
it's for selective surgery for money to
make lots of money in the United States
they heart testing and if you and this
is a couple weeks back you would have to
be you have to pay to be tested I mean
there's something some exorbitant amount
of money and then if you if you found to
be sick there's not much they can do
for you maybe okay I mean the
outsourcing of all of this is to the
point of criminality in my opinion here
and I don't think there's anything wrong
to talk about health security okay and I
think this is a crisis it should tell us
about that okay and it talks about a
medical system of a for-profit that is
on trial here and it is being convicted
over and over again and the government
is culpable because it's all based on
special interests
go ahead Joseph yeah well it appears
that all countries around the world
we're strong unprepared by the corner
virus crisis even despite the fact they
knew what's happening in China this is
this is this is very striking because
would be this strategical community
within these countries were doing they
knew what's coming on them and at the
moment it appears for instance the US
healthcare system lacked mechanism to
tackle the deadly virus outbreak the
latest research of Imperial College in
London shows that it was if left
unchecked the disease could exceed the
capacity of US health care system by 30
percent and will cost life around 2.2
million people in the country be careful
here they've talked back those numbers a
bit since that report came out so I want
to make clarification on that however
your point is well-taken here okay Anya
this is something that people knew that
was going to happen they knew that a
pandemic of this kind could happen and
and they were warned over and over again
and they refused to take it on board
because it would be costly okay I mean
we again with the epicenter of all of
this is 2008-2009 when we recognized the
fragility and basically the corruption
of the system here and it was covered up
it was and actually encouraged to
continue developing it okay it was like
a flat tire that you just keep pumping
in air it will still work but you get
negative returns okay because the whole
gets bigger and bigger and this is what
it took a virus like this to show the
the Sham nature of the economic system
here and who it serves it doesn't serve
works it doesn't serve families and
that's where I have common cause with
recives go ahead if you're absolutely
correct not only in the lead up to this
outbreak were they ignoring the pandemic
now that it's happening in the United
States it really feels as though it's
taken weeks for our government to even
begin taking this seriously and I have
equal contempt for Democrats and
Republicans alike in the US Congress who
passed through the stimulus bill you had
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes the young
up-and-coming
progressive from New York deleted fire
which on the floor but then not take any
action in order to actually demonstrate
her opposition to the bill I found that
to be slightly fraudulent instead you
had the congressman from Kentucky Thomas
Massie taking a very bold stance and
foreign and trying to force members of
Congress to actually publicly declare
their vote on the largest stimulus bill
passed in the history of the United
States and Peter you're exactly correct
in 2009 in 2008 during the crisis of the
economy in that point people in
Washington people in New York didn't
actually take any lessons and reform the
system at all
they only pumped more money back into
the same broken debt ridden false dead
system and now we're dealing with a
situation where those many years ago
when we had an economic collapse in the
States we were only shedding somewhere
between 700 and 800 thousand jobs a
month at the height of the crisis now
we're dealing with millions of people in
weeks in just a matter of weeks signing
up for unemployment benefits we have no
idea how badly this will impact the
economy weeks and months down the line
as people stay inside and aren't
spending money when our entire economy
is driven on this I'm curious about
what's going to happen to an economy
that has had endless amounts of cash
pumped into it for the people at the top
when the people at the bottom stop
spending are we going to experience
inflation in the United States
I really wonder I really wondered Peter
and I fear and especially now when you
see over the last several days
Federal Reserve making the decision that
it will actually buy for the first time
in its history direct stocks in US
companies I wonder at the end of all of
this which industries which major
corporations in the United States that
we take for granted today will have
failed as a result of this crisis and
could even be owned by the US government
where will that leave us and you have
this mantra being against socialism it's
just the Fed gets to pick winners I
thought that's what socialist countries
did I mean the you know there's no
self-reflection whatsoever on what
they're doing here John let's change our
gears a little bit to Europe you're
talking maybe our viewers in
particularly in North America may not be
aware of how the European Union is
treated Italy in Spain through all of
this and in the future of the EU as a
result go ahead well you have to
distinguish between the European Union
and the European Union member states the
European Union member states were asked
early on in the crisis by Italy to send
various supplies including masks and so
on the things I referred to earlier and
Germany and other countries France I
think said no and indeed the European
Commission I understand also said no
including to Serbia by the way the
serbian president made a very emotional
statement after after this refusal by
europe to help so and that has created
enormous resentment I've mentioned
Serbia but much more importantly is
Italy because obviously Italy is a found
a member of the EU and there is terrible
resentment now in Italy towards the
richer northern countries and towards
Brussels for their failure to do
anything so I think you know without
again we're wishing too too much say
that this proves that I was right it is
very difficult to see how the European
project can recover but particularly
since the debate has now moved on to the
issue of raising even more debt all
these countries are drowning in debt
already but some in Italy and other in
other countries want bombs want European
bonds to be floated in order to raise
debt
the corona crisis in other words for
there to be a European debt issue the
Dutch and the Germans for the time being
is saying no to that and that will only
further I think exacerbate what everyone
thinks are the rights and wrongs of the
issue this hostility within Italy itself
to the European project and to its
European neighbors and God knows where
that will lead the Europe the Italian
government is relatively fragile it came
about after the league the Italian
league under Matteo salvini was thrown
out before the crisis of salvini was by
far the most popular politician in Italy
and the league is the biggest yet we
don't know where this could go
and you tell Italy is famous for having
instant unstable governments one outcome
is definitely that salvini could be back
but in this time in charge of majority
government yeah well we couldn't up the
whole European least a sudden southern
members of the European Union their
future may be Greece's it's not
impossible you know the issue of debt
here you also if living go to you I mean
you know John and I have known each
other for very many years and we've
talked about the European Union and
neoliberalism a lot I mean you're in
Europe right now I mean the the every
time there's been a crisis in the
European Union the answer from the elite
says we need more Europe can they make
that can they make that pitch right now
we need more Europe well you can Union
has firm itself it's true in itself is
unable to solve large international
crises during the migration crisis and
it is the same issue right now they
easily trace illustrate the true nature
of international relations at times of
crisis the states are firstly trying to
secure their survival while self-help
and once their survival is ensured we
seek to help others who need it it is
well documented in the cases of Italy
Spain and Serbia the EU has established
the Union civil protection mechanism as
an active part of the Union
international crisis of its member and
it's maybe Member States crisis and the
mechanism doesn't work because nobody
wants to contribute to that mechanism
because everybody cares for themselves
so what does it tell us about the
European Union now but Joseph's agony
you hear but I mean this is the the
tension here okay is that what does
sovereignty mean I mean this is it's
tested all of the time here and they
kick the can down the road when you have
Italy in Spain when they are part of
this glorious Union the highest you know
civilization in the history of humanity
okay this is shining you know light on
the hill as I like to see themselves but
when two important members get in
trouble they they're left alone okay and
and and they're invoking their
sovereignty that's the last thing you
can invoke I so that's of calling 9-1-1
your sovereignty because it was no
reaction from Brussels and a rejection
from the Germans here I mean this is the
single biggest problem in dealing with
they in my way globally globalization
and neoliberalism is what does
sovereignty mean going finish up before
I go to Anya yes so yes that's the point
that the European Union is just business
model
it doesn't serve at times of crisis it's
not nothing more and if the European
Union wants to proceed to another level
of integration then it needs to
incorporate the emergency bodies which
are actually worse because there is
another migration wave coming from
Turkey right now will be hit by summer
what the European Union will do right
now nobody knows because it's even
unable to reach a deal how to tackle the
economy crisis when that happens Joseph
you're gonna come back here and tell me
how they're going to do it I want to
finish up with you I think we see eye to
eye on so many issues here and the thing
that's really I'm really glad because I
think there needs to be a bridge in a
conversation here we're gonna see a lot
of real painting here but it's very
interesting the whole world most of the
Western world is shut down and it was
shut down very quickly and relatively
easy how are working people and
unemployed people going to be able to
react to this crisis if they can be just
locked down intimidated this is what
terrifies me the in at least speaking as
an
American the entire Constitution is
being put into quarantine how do we
react on you go ahead it is concerning
because if we reflect on some of the
points all of the guests today made
we're all agreeing that what we're
facing now is way more intense and more
frightening than what we faced even in
2008 and 2009 and that's when we saw for
example the emergence of the Occupy Wall
Street movement in the United States and
massive protests throughout Europe in
response to the crisis of neoliberal as
neoliberalism and capitalism and this
critique emerged and because of the very
nature of the pandemic crisis were
facing now we're not going to be able to
go into the streets when you have the
President of the United States calling
up reservist members of the military as
he did last week and say that he's
keeping them called up to duty for up to
two years we have to wonder where those
boots are going to be I don't think
they're going to be abroad I think
they're going to be set up between state
lines in the United States and on one
hand I think it's necessary that we
respond to this health crisis
appropriately but there's no denying
what you've said Peter which is that
there is going to be an economic
catastrophe to come as a result of this
I think as with many aspects of US
policy and Empire with the Trump
administration much of it has been laid
bare and not only in the United States
and not only when it comes to the United
States but all of the systems have been
relying on right the EU global economic
trade to the level that we're not even
producing basic things such as surgical
masks and ventilators in the United
States or in Europe but we're depending
on countries on the other side of the
world to produce those goods all of that
needs to change this crisis has revealed
that we didn't really have a federal
government in the United States let
alone in Europe so I think people are
going to have to they're gonna have no
choice because I'm very frightened but
at this point all I can say that I'm
frightened we have the end of program
but I'm gonna send it on a very positive
note I want to congratulate you
your marriage to max Blumenthal
congratulations both of you I hope to
see you all soon that's all the time we
have I wanted to come to Moscow but now
I want to thank my guests in Washington
France and in Bratislava and I want to
thank our viewers for watching us here
at RT see you next time remember
crosstalk rules
[Music]